bringing mike florio the popular co-host
of pro football talk live
mike how are you this morning good you
know fritzy reminds me of the michael
scott
approach to a wedding toast you just
have a bunch of different things lined
up
until one lands but he doesn't get out
that's the problem fritzi just keeps
going
uh here's our poll question if you could
pick
you gotta you gotta pick one you wanna
be daniel jones last night dan arlovsky
running out of the end zone or mark
sanchez with a fumble
oh boy wow
probably orlovsky running out of the end
zone because that one has
had some relative staying power but it's
not over the top i
roll groan every time you see it it's
just kind of funny and light the butt
fumble is just kind of like the ultimate
grown inducer
daniel jones i have no idea how long
this one's gonna last i have a feeling
it's gonna stick with him as long as
he's in the league so i'll go
i'll go a or b or whatever it was
orlowski
yeah but i got to give daniel jones
credit for being athletic for 70 yards
orlovsky and sanchez there's nothing
athletic about what they did there
and daniel jones afterwards said hey i
just tried to run
faster you know how many times have we
seen guys run to the end zone and they
look up and they can
check on the video board that no one is
close enough to tackle them
he just has like no awareness which is
not surprising because in the pocket he
has no awareness maybe that's his
biggest flaw
because he's got the physical skills for
at least 80 yards not for the final 87.
do you think if the giants are on the
clock for the number one or number two
pick overall that they would consider a
quarterback
i think you have to you have to do the
evaluation you have to
be objective and understand who's out
there so you can make a decision about
whether
the vows with the guy you have and one
of the big decisions is are they going
to keep
their gm dave gettleman if it's the new
gm
then the first order of business may be
to bring in a new quarterback a new
franchise quarterback a guy that you
believe
will be the next 15-year option they
thought it was going to be daniel jones
so far it hasn't been again ball
security is a problem awareness in the
pocket is a problem
i don't know how much that you can coach
out of a guy but with a new coaching
staff there
if they end up with a new gm i think it
becomes more urgent but
whoever you are you need to put in the
time
to look at all of the top prospects and
understand their strengths and their
weaknesses because even if you're
trading that pick
you want to be able to get the most out
of that pick and the more you know about
the guy
the better suited you're going to be to
negotiate with whoever would want to
come up and try to get that pick from
you
are the vikings tanking
well i don't know i mean some of these
teams you ask are they tanking why are
you don't you have to try to tank
i don't even know that they're doing it
deliberately but once you start selling
off parts
that necessarily bumps up the depth
chart a lesser guy
which makes your team easier to beat i
mean jonathan gawkway had
four sats in five games for the vikings
he's fifth in the nfl so he's a guy who
can play
and and they've moved on from him and
they save six million dollars it gets
carried over to next year under the
salary cap but they don't spend it this
year which will come in handy but
you know it feels like they're thinking
about a rebuild they were trying to do
kind of a reload rebuild kind of change
a tire on a moving car
and that's not working obviously for the
vikings so they've got a lot to do
to try to figure out who they're going
to be what they're going to be and i
think this is the first step toward
acknowledging it
and planning for the future whatever the
future may entail but it may take a few
years
because they're going to have some guys
that they're stuck with for a while like
kirk cousins
that that they're not going to be able
to move on from easily after the season
if the jets had the number one pick and
you were trevor lawrence's agent
what would you advise him to do well
look i'm a firm believer in a player
making a power play whenever and
wherever he can
i don't like the draft in that it
prevents these kids from picking where
they're going to start
their career because look where you go
who's around you
who your coach is that so much shapes
how you're ultimately perceived as a
quarterback you need to land in a spot
where
you want to be with people you want to
work for with players you want to play
with so
i'm always going to say to the first
overall pick in the draft you've got a
hell of a lot more leverage
than you realize if you don't want to go
play for that team
say you're not going to do it don't
worry if you get criticized don't worry
if the fans
are upset with you say you're not going
to do it and make that power play that
doesn't happen nearly enough
the raiders game against the buccaneers
was going to be sunday night now it's
sunday afternoon
seattle's game against arizona sunday
afternoon now sunday night are the
raiders going to be able to when are we
going to find out if the raiders are
going to be able to play this game
well you know they've got got and this
is the the reality of the
the revised covert protocols where guys
get sent home even if they don't have it
but they've been in close enough contact
with a guy who has it that everyone's
being careful and everyone's being safe
well
you don't get guys ready for games that
way and you may not have guys able to
play that way so
i think we'll find out at some point
today but the raiders are still going to
be at a disadvantage
and they deserve to be at a disadvantage
you know the nfl huston puff but
ultimately didn't blow the house down
for the tennessee titans a couple of
weeks ago
i think we're at the point now where
teams need to be held accountable
coaches need to be held accountable
coaches control everything how is john
gruden not better controlling his guys
to keep this kind of stuff from
happening and we've seen it time and
again with the raiders
so maybe the best punishment is sorry
coach you have to go play a game on
sunday
and you're not ready your players aren't
ready you're down
seven guys too bad you should have done
a better job of keeping
everyone in compliance with the protocol
so hopefully we find out today
i'm kind of getting used to the monday
night
tuesday night it's kind of like they've
discovered plutonium by accident with
this
where this is kind of a good thing and
maybe we need to start thinking about
these windows two monday night games in
the tuesday night game going forward
i want to see tom brady and john gruden
i want to see that game
and i got a better chance and most
people have a better chance of seeing it
if it's played in prime time so maybe we
get another monday or tuesday night game
out of this
and i keep reminding people about the
nfc east yes somebody has to win this
division
but the team that wins that division
gets to host a playoff game
and you wouldn't you might be shocked to
find out or think
they could actually win a home playoff
game you know with no
you know crowd there for a home field
advantage but if you say to me the
eagles or cowboys are going to be
hosting
the saints in the opener of a playoff
game or the rams
i don't i mean it's not out of the realm
of possibilities that
that team no matter what its record is
is going to win that first playoff game
with maybe a sub 500 record ten years
ago the seahawks were seven and nine the
saints were eleven and five the
defending nfl champions had to go to
seattle in seattle one and people were
like well that shows seattle's the
better teams like are you kidding me
you play that game in new orleans new
orleans wins by 30. homefield advantage
does matter
and i don't like this current structure
of the nfl i don't like
four teams in a division because all you
have to be is the best of four crappy
teams and we come up
against this every year or every other
year
why don't they go back to three
divisions per conference
and and yeah one division is going to
have six teams oh well
five six and five damn back in the 70s
with four five and four
they don't have to have the same number
of teams it doesn't have to be perfect
symmetry
i don't like the idea that you just have
a one in four chance of making the
playoffs
and hosting a game and peter king and i
were talking about this earlier
the fact that it is a one and four
chance means you're never going to get
24 owners
to vote to change it because they all
look at it and say hey
any given year all we have to be is the
best of these four teams
and we win our division and we host a
playoff game
and that's why it's never going to
change but it should and hopefully
hopefully there's going to be a year
where it's five and eleven hosting
twelve and four
and they'll be an outcry and the nfl
will have to change it
have a good good weekend mike all right
see you there that's the mike florio
co-host pro football talk live on
peacock with
chris sims